you considered doing stand-up at one
point and you you weren't sure you
wanted to risk going up on stage in
front of people who might be hostile so
you made a tape mm-hmm and you made a
tape that you wanted to show here on the
show well I made a tape with my dear
friend the wonderful stand-up comedian
Steve Agee I posted it on YouTube
clearly it was a submission for your
show I was about 23 so right it's taken
a while to talk about it we're very busy
here you know we're we got a lot going
on here we're getting a lot of fan
Corrections coming in there's a lot
going on but should we can we take a
look at your tape right now let me show
it to everyone let's see Ellen page's
stand-up audition for our show take a
look hey everybody how's it going
tonight my name is Ellen Page and this
is my submission tape for the Conan
O'Brien show um so the other day I was
hanging out with my friend who's a
hardcore anarchist
and I offered her some local honey for
her coffee and she refused and I said
are you are you a vegan and she said yes
and I said well why don't you eat honey
because bees make honey
that's you know that's what they do and
she said I disagree with the politics of
the hive because the Queen
singing of the Queen I'm Canadian
a and penny there's a picture of the
Queen on one side of her face and on the
other side there's a beaver
[Applause]
fixated